neutron stars are the densest things
that are not black holes
in their cause we might find the most
dangerous substance in existence
strange matter
a bizarre thing so extreme that it bends
the rules of the universe
and could infect and destroy everything
it comes into contact with
or it could teach us about how the
universe began
maybe both
[Music]
[Music]
to understand how extreme strange matter
really is we first need to get a few
basics
what is a neutron star and how does
strange matter break the rules of the
universe
to get all of this into one video we'll
grossly over simplify a few things but
we'll provide you with further reading
if you want more details
a neutron star is what remains after a
very massive star explodes in a
supernova
when this happens the star's core
collapses under its own gravity with
such a strong inward force that it
squeezes nuclei and particles together
violently
electrons are pushed into protons so
they merge and turn into neutrons
although nothing inside of atoms is
suddenly completely filled with
particles that really don't want to be
close to each other but have no choice
they desperately push back against
gravity against the collapse
if gravity wins they will become a black
hole if they win they become a neutron
star
this makes neutron stars like giant
atomic nuclei the size of a city but
holding the mass of our sun
and here things get weird
the environment in the core of neutron
stars is so extreme that the rules of
nuclear physics change
and this could lead to a strange and
extremely dangerous substance
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
we first need to know the rules before
we learn how they can be broken
protons and neutrons the particles
making up the nuclei of atoms are made
up of smaller particles called quarks
quarks really don't want to be alone
they are what we call confined
you can try to separate them but the
harder you pull the harder they try to
pull themselves back together
if you use a lot of energy they just use
this energy to create new quarks
quarks only exist together as the
building blocks of other particles and
have never been observed by themselves
they come in many types but only two
appear to make stable matter
the up and down quarks found in protons
and neutrons
all other quarks seem to decay away
quickly
but this may be different inside neutron
stars
the forces operating in their cores are
so extreme that they are actually
similar to the universe shortly after
the big bang
neutron star cores are like fossils
which can let us peer back in time to
the beginning of everything
so learning how quarks behave inside a
neutron star is a way of understanding
the very nature of the universe itself
one hypothesis is that inside a neutron
star core protons and neutrons deconfine
all the particles crammed shoulder to
shoulder dissolve and melt into a sort
of bath of quarks
uncountable numbers of particles become
one giant thing made purely from quarks
quark matter
a star made from this is called a quark
star though from the outside it may not
look any different than a regular
neutron star
now we can finally talk about the most
dangerous substance if the pressure
inside a quark star is great enough it
may get stranger
literally
in the cause of neutron stars some of
the quarks may be converted into strange
quarks
strange quarks have bizarre nuclear
properties and they are heavier and for
the lack of a better word stronger
if they turn up they could create
strange matter
strange matter might be the ideal state
of matter perfectly dense perfectly
stable indestructible
more stable than any other matter in the
universe
so stable that it can exist outside
neutron stars
if this is the case we have a problem
it might be infectious
every piece of matter it touches might
be so impressed by its stability that it
would immediately turn into strange
matter too
protons and neutrons would dissolve and
become part of the quark bath which
frees energy and creates more strange
matter
the only way to get rid of it would be
to throw it into a black hole
but then again
who cares all of it is inside neutron
stars
except when neutron stars collide with
other neutron stars or black holes they
spew out tremendous amounts of their
insides some of which could include
little droplets of strange matter called
strangelets
strangelets are as dense as the core of
a neutron star
they could be really small maybe even
subatomic but even the largest
strangelets wouldn't be any bigger than
a rocket
these strangelets would drift through
the galaxy for millions or billions of
years until they meet a star or planet
by chance
if one were to strike earth it would
immediately start converting it into
strange matter the more it converts the
more it would grow
ultimately all of the atoms making up
earth would be converted
earth would become a hot clump of
strange matter the size of an asteroid
if a strange lit strikes the sun it
would collapse into a strange star
eating through it like fire through a
dry forest
this would not change the sun's mass
much but it would become way less bright
so earth would freeze to death
and like a tiny virus we'd have no way
to see a strange lick coming
worse still some theories suggest
strangelets are more than common
outnumbering all stars in the galaxy
these strangelets could have formed very
early after the big bang when it was as
hot and dense as a neutron star core
everywhere
they might be clumping around the
gravity of galaxies as the universe
expanded and evolved
strangelets could even be so numerous
and massive that they might actually be
the dark matter we suspect holds
galaxies together
but then again maybe not
this is speculation and the earth and
sun and planets haven't been consumed in
a wildfire of strangelets in the past
few billion years so the odds seem good
that it won't happen anytime soon
understanding these strange objects
today may be the key to understanding
the birth of our universe and why it
grew to look the way it does now
when scientists first started playing
with magnets and wires and thinking
about electrons they had no idea how
technology would evolve in the next
hundred years
the scientists thinking about the cause
of neutron stars and strange matter
today may be setting up humans for a
future beyond our wildest imaginations
or maybe not
time will tell
so while you're waiting to see if the
universe gets destroyed you might still
want to find out more about it we've got
you our friends from brilliant can be
your insight into a whole world of
science black holes and all brilliant is
a website that helps you tackle science
in a practical way with interactive
problem-solving courses and daily
challenges in maths logic and
engineering each problem gives you all
the tools you need to crack complex
topics all by yourself it's learning by
doing but with your brain instead of
your hands
use your curiosity to get to the bottom
of puzzles and courses about things like
classical mechanics astronomy
gravitational physics and much more
if you click the link in the description
or visit brilliant.org nutshell you can
sign up for free and learn more things
than you can imagine
and there's an extra perk for kotskazak
viewers the first 688 people to use the
link get 20 off their annual membership
which lets you view all the daily
problems in the archives and unlock
every course
brilliant helps you end your day a
little smarter you might get hooked on
the experience
[Music]
you